hey Alice just let me know informing you
your demographic kids you know what kids
really like superhero movies just saying
this might have been a pretty stupid
weekend to open up on him just saying
promise you to come out against money
monster or something you're done why
this weekend
Alice Through the Looking Glass so Alice
Through the Looking Glass is the sequel
to the 2010 I believe it was Alice in
Wonderland by Tim Burton in this movie
spent a few years Alice she goes through
a mirror to Wonderland the Hatters
crazies ultimately narrowing it down for
you saving it time she goes and sees
time played by Sacha Baron Cohen steals
his Chronos spirit and now she can
travel through time and she hops through
different times in Wonderland's history
because she wants to change an event in
the Hatters past so he's not crazy
anymore
sounds pretty epic honestly time travel
and Alice in Wonderland changing the
past it's this could be epic folks first
of all I actually like Sacha Baron
Cohen's character in the movie I mean
Sasha Baron Cohen playing him he had
some jokes that landed some that didn't
I was more impressed with the fact that
he's actually not a villain he's just
time and time needs to stop Alice from
doing this because she's gonna destroy
existence as we know it so he's
constantly pursuing ergs he hasn't go
after her and stop her and you can kind
of see Alice as the villain in that case
she does threaten everything that's bad
and like I said I have a soft spot for
time movies and time stories so when you
have Alice in Wonderland going through
time it's just kind of innately I'm like
alright I'm on your side all you can do
now is lose me but the movie had enough
that kind of lost me first of all
everyone in this movie except Alice
herself is an exaggerated version of
what they're supposed to be it's like
everyone took an acting page from Johnny
Depp's book and they're like hey it
works for him we're just gonna do
exactly what he does all the time and I
get Wonder Lance kind of a kooky place
but when everybody acts that way even
the ones who are probably supposed to be
sane it starts to get to you Johnny Depp
once again has two or three different
voices as the Mad Hatter Anne Hathaway's
always walking around like this the
Queen of Hearts is in this movie again
played by Helena Bonham Carter once
again once again she just screams all of
her lines because she's supposed to be
angry and I know the Queen of Hearts
does that but you can change things for
the enjoyment of the audience I'm just
saying her screaming got annoying I mean
Alice goes to the past where you see the
Queen of Hearts at Anne Hathaway's
character the queen of super white
things and their younger selves actually
talk like real human beings they
interact like girls interact it was
actually pretty normal and pretty
refreshing in the movie apparently when
they grow up the Queen of Hearts yells
at everything and Anne Hathaway acts
like this when she walks and really the
movie is one of those they go to a time
they're not even there long enough to
they make it resonate they're like um
yeah we gotta go to the other one but go
to the other one she's like all right
one or two things happening alright
let's go to another place so it's a
classic case of a movie that wants to
show you so much it's a pitstop movie
now it's like alright pitstop
alright moving pitstop alright moving
pitstop throughout the movie until the
end the end the starts get a little epic
you're biting your nails you're like oh
holy crap I can't say I wasn't
entertained in that respect and I can't
say I wasn't entertained in parts
throughout the movie I was also annoyed
in parts throughout the movie so it's a
mixed bag movie guys in the end Alice
Through the Looking Glass I enjoyed this
one more than the first one that's not
to say I enjoyed it enough for me to be
like yeah you need to see it right now I
would say it'd be great for families to
go to bless face it x-men apocalypse
came out this weekend too so if you have
kids your kids are already bribing you
to let them see that movie Looking Glass
had some cool stuff it had some annoying
stuff conceptually it's cool I liked the
time stuff I just didn't like all of the
execution of the time stuff in the end
the movie actually came across as kind
of boring but visually awesome Alice
Through the Looking Glass probably be a
better time if you were drunk yeah now
it's a party I'm watching this rather
than the x-men movie well how many
drinks did I have alright guys so Alice
Through the Looking Glass have you seen
it what did you think about it or what's
the most annoying movie you've ever seen
that's I don't think I've asked that yet
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more